if you see him maybe give him a hug Tom
Schwartz dishing all things scandaval on
Watch What Happens live with Andy Cohen
give him a hug he's down bad now
Schwartz's ex Katie Maloney and
Vanderpump Rules cast mate Lala Kent are
giving their two cents on all that did
schwartzie really just say if you see
Sandoval in the street give him a hug
we're punching him straight in the Tom I
have two words for you media training
the reality star was put on the spot
Wednesday night as Andy Cohen grilled
him about Tom Sandoval and Raquel
levis's Affair I'm not defending him as
a close friend you got to let him figure
it out for himself Schwartz revealed
that he found out about friends one
Kel in August
the alleged continued fling which ended
Sandoval's nine-year relationship with
Ariana Maddox until January from my
point of view it became like an
emotional affair which is still
inappropriate okay yeah inappropriate
seems to be the general consensus among
the cast including former Vanderpump
Rules star Jax Taylor
he's been with Ariana for yes almost 10
years there's lack of empathy there it
was like a premeditated situation but it
was this comment that had people shook
if you see him maybe give him a hug even
if he doesn't deserve it yeah that
didn't sit well with Schwartz's ex-wife
who
quited you're
have the tendency to have a very sharp
tongue and she let him know that she
wasn't impressed on her insta story you
were just gonna say whatever lands in
your head and that's not good as for
Lala the whole thing had her worked up
every time I sit here and say
I'm over scanned of all one of those
people
just meets another level of buffoonery a
course fans of the show and fellow Bravo
Liberties have been quick to support
Ariana like real housewives of Potomac
star Candace Dillard Ariana girl you can
do better and summer houses Lindsay
Hubbard my heart really hurt for Ariana
I just can't imagine that level of
betrayal he was messing around with
one of your best friends like that is
so messed up on so many levels while
Vanderpump alums Jax Taylor and Brittany
Cartwright haven't been on the show for
the past two seasons they're still good
friends with most of the cast and have
been in touch with orianna since
scandaval first erupted I've checked in
on Ariana a couple times I know that she
hasn't been alone for a second so that
was good and Schwartz admits he's not
happy with Sandoval either it's an
unspoken rule you we've all agreed to
practice radical honesty with each other
he took advantage of my kindness and he
put a lot of people not just myself and
very compromising situations where our
integrity was at stake I think he just
became Tom has ADHD and honestly he
became obsessed Raquel is Tom's heroine
well fans of the show will just have to
wait and see how all the drama unfolds
as season 10 plays out
you want anything for you to die
foreign